hey everyone its micromotor flows and
this is a follow-up video to yesterday's
video in the morning in the mini Dow
that I was trading that I was doing now
you know in the morning I took a handful
of trades and you know I ended up by a
hundred blocks up on that day but at
that time then I had you know I had to
go out and do stuff bunch of errands and
things like that and I got home around 1
o'clock and and I started trading again
but before I jump in a brief disclaimer
you know you gotta go through these
things is this presentation is for
educational informational purposes only
should not be considered a solicitation
to buy or sell a futures contract or
making other type of investment decision
futures train contain substantial risk
and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all that
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk Apple
should be used for trading in only those
with sufficient risk Apple should
consider trading platform it's not
necessarily indicative of future results
now again you know don't don't expect
your results to be exactly like mine you
know you're gonna take different trades
from you know depending on how fast you
are and you're able to recognize what's
going on but you know just after 1
o'clock about 112 we hit our high and we
had a divergence you know we had the
negative Delta the new high the red
candle this was actually a very nice one
and and I sort of kicked myself because
I wasn't you know fully into it I was
still you know eating because I just
come back in and I needed to eat as well
and and this was a nice move you know we
went from down from the you know the 115
area down into the 80s I got short here
at 80 you know we got this a little bit
of a bounce I like this type of a bounce
here in the order flow you know it's all
negative Delta even here you know you
got the green bar it's still negative
Delta comes right back in the small bar
you know 3 is the Delta which is very
neutral and you know the problem I was
having yesterday I was very late in my
entries and you know I was trying to
sell it in here eventually I got short I
got my order filled at 80 but I gave up
at least five five ticks by missing it
in this bar and you know I covered it at
you know the ATM that I was using it was
the wrong one and it just automatically
through and I take profit of 10 ticks
it just happened so fast that by the
time I realized that I you know that was
I was out already so anyway you know
that was a nice little tentacle winner
then later you know I was trying to be a
little bit selective on some of my
trades I got short here and I got short
at 46 I got stopped out you know and I I
liked this the way that was setting up
here for being short and you know it
didn't work and I got stopped out that a
tenth a clause which is okay you know I
don't like it you know I just gave away
everything I just made in the last trade
now then we started coming back down
here again this was kind of similar to
that one that I was just showing you the
one that I took right after one o'clock
and you know coming down boom I got
short at ten and again you know it was
one of those I felt I was a little bit
late on I'm coming in you know I
normally I I just started don't say just
started trading I haven't tried to Dow
mini doll for a long time and you know
I've been talking to somebody and he's
like how you guys started trading dial
you I start trading down it and it moves
a lot faster than the e minis and but
you know you get some nice moves if
you're right you get you know some very
decent moves very quick I mean the
Nasdaq is a little bit too fast for my
blood right now you know you can in
trading got a fine contract that suits
your personality and you know that I
said you know I haven't traded mini Dow
really since I left JPMorgan and even my
trading there the style was was a bit
different you know because I was I was
trading a lot bigger size and I could
sort of bully the market a little bit
when when I wanted to and plus I was
training at nighttime well because I was
I was overseas working so it wasn't the
u.s. session and it moves a lot faster
than it does obviously in the off hours
or the overnight session if you will but
anyway you know I got short here at
10:00 again I was late on my entry
wanting to get in a little bit better up
here at 15 but anyway you know I could
pitch really got short at 10:00 ended up
covering it down here at 55 so this is a
nice 15 tape winner and then this one
again
this is one where I say I had a lot of
hope in this trade but I sort of grew
frustrated with it um you know got short
at OAD I'm covering it at the double-o
and you know why is because you know
this this bar here you know I thought it
was kind of bullish and at the time I
was reading the order flow you know we
sort of spike down here and there's some
supportive buying in here I'm not much
being traded on the offer side and you
know oftentimes I see bars like this and
it just sort of rallies up and up and up
so you know I had a bit in I had my bit
down here around 90 but ended up just
putting it down here I thought you know
we may come down here sort of test these
you know this this area down in here and
then start the rally you know but it
just broke down and you know sold off
some more so that was a little a think
winner
nothing special this one this one yeah
this one really pissed me off actually I
got short of 12 I don't know why I
covered it at o8 because there was
putting in a lot of volume down here
yeah I don't like that you know I like
the moves to be fast you know like if
you look back here boom you know just
the bar you know yeah I could pull up
but then boom you know and boom again
you know what with not much volume being
traded on the offer side you know if the
markets going down that that's what I'm
looking for where as opposed to the
market going up and we start putting a
lot of volume in here which you know
kind of Concerned me a bit you know we
had when I covered it at Oh 8 you know
we had put the volume in here the
support of volume you know then we got
that push but you know at that time I
yeah I could have been a little bit more
patient but you know what there's
getting back here is ready after 2
o'clock and I was just like you know why
why do I still want to be trading at
this time or not and you know this was a
nice move you know from 12 all the way
down to you know gosh down into the 70s
but I think there was one more trade I
took here I think there's two more
trades 46 I got short here again again
this is type of trade that I like
you know market selling off get a little
bit of a pullback and boom you know made
a nice move from 46 down to you know I
covered a 30 so let's put a 16 tick
winner and again you know I like the
move to be pretty quick pretty fast I
mean put in the volume but it happened
very fast so I really wasn't too
concerned and then again you know I'm
staring at all this negative Delta in
here so I'm not uh not so worried that
that this market might bounce up I mean
he started bouncing up here but I
already covered it eventually it came
off came off some more I think this is
my last trade of the day and the reason
was my last trade of the days because I
felt I got lucky I end up getting short
again here at 12 and boom the market
started rallying it rallied rallied
rallied rallied up to 25 I think it was
25 26 came back down and then I just
started seeing signs here in the order
flow you know this ball I'm here 110 you
know 16 into the next bar and I started
rallying I put in my bid to sort of
cover it I actually had it in at 11 to
break you plus a tick I'm very very
fortunate that I got it
and very traded very few in there and
then the market went back up before
coming down you know before making that
move that I was looking for but again
you know if I'm short here at 12 and its
trading 30 I don't want to be short
anymore and most likely I would have
just covered it and take my loss and
curse the world but you know I said you
know I got I caught a break there and I
was happy for it and you know so I ended
up the day that was it for the day I had
to go out again in the afternoon so you
know net net the day was ok they took a
total of 12 trades and you know after
commissions and all that funky stuff
ended up was it up 266 bucks so you know
twelve trades net profit was 320 and so
266 in the green so I mean it was can
it's nothing special again but you know
and that's just trading one Lots right
and you know sometimes people
thinking oh I gotta be trading yeah you
got to be trading ten Lots or something
like that you know to make any
meaningful profit you know that's
trading one Lots over a period was
essentially at one hour in the morning
one hour in the afternoon and again you
know not everybody's gonna results are
gonna be typical you know I don't know
maybe it was just a lucky day I don't
think so but um you know I'm gonna you
know today is Thursday the third of me
and you know we'll see um you know if I
get some trade if I feel like starting
it was bringing like a mother fish here
last night and I mean I'm in Chicago and
I woke up this morning feel like I'm
catching a cold so hopefully I don't get
sick but I just you know I sort of woke
up and I just wanted to stay in bed but
um you know we'll see if there's going
to be any decent trades you know I've
been putting forth the idea that you
know if I can do it as far as finding
the time so I might just start streaming
live you know showing you guys trades
I'm taken you know in real time I don't
know yet you know I said I'm still
trying to find that common ground that
can please everybody and can sort of
show them you know how I trade with
order flow and and how you can - alright
I mean you know you see my charts you
know they're like the only things I
really have on here right now on this
chart is just you know imbalances but
again you know it's mini Dow so it's you
know if I were to set the volume
indicator some of these all these
imbalances wouldn't show up but um you
know it's not like I got a lot of
squiggly lines or anything like that I
saw some guy in this chart had so many
different lines on it I couldn't see
where we were trading because there's so
many lines I don't even know where the
court what the market was you know where
the market was at but you know but
anyway hopefully you found this video
useful and I hope to get another one off
for you today as well so thanks everyone
and have a great day bye-bye